welcome back guys to PAX East 2019
this is the iron Lords podcast and loads
of gaming dotnet I'm Lord sovereign and
I'm here with Jeff from the brand new
game anew the distant light so Jeff
thank you for joining us tell us a
little bit about yourself what you do on
the game and what the game is about sure
yeah thanks a lot for having me on your
show yep so I won half of resonator
which is an independent game studio
we're making our debut indie game anew
the distant light essentially like we
sort of describe it as a it's called the
metroidvania so gamers sort of know what
that means a big open world
interconnected game world that you have
to explore and fight through so yeah
basically the premise of our game is in
the opening moments you kind of see that
the lower half of Earth has been blown
away and you're a little baby and you're
loaded onto a spaceship and sent 20
light-years out into space and you land
on this sort of strange surreal alien
moon and as a 20 year old you come down
to the surface and have to explore your
way through the world to find out what
your mission is and what happened on
earth on your home planet yeah so in
terms of mechanics what can we expect
that's different from what people would
consider your typical Metroidvania yeah
yeah great question so typically in
these types of games you're on foot
right a lot you know most of the game
time in our game what we want to do is
like add a wide variety of movement
types so we have spent a long time on
like an underwater animation and
so we have a zone in our game that's
like in this frozen lake so there's this
huge area that you have to swim through
and Jetpack underwater and so great and
we also have what we're most excited
about is the addition of these like
crazy over powered vehicles really so we
have like this massive screen filling
Mac we have a sort of like a warthog
inspired dune buggie rocket ships flying
saucer that sort of helps to you know
keep the gameplay keep the gameplay
brush yeah exactly so in terms of in
terms of power-ups and and typical
things you would find that I mention
Romania which allow you to progress
beyond parts that you normally couldn't
at certain parts of the game like what
type of stuff yeah so we've got some of
the classic you know ability upgrades
like sliding double jump we have like a
really cool jetpack that works above and
below water geez what else faster
movement type sprinting skating on ice a
couple other things we haven't actually
revealed yet in arguing but plenty of
stuff that a swimming suit
so you can actually swim underwater okay
yeah quite quite a bit of fun stuff so
apart from the vehicles and whatnot
beyond that where how do you feel your
game takes to the metroidvania genre to
another level
yeah so on top of all that stuff that's
not another lore
we're doing some really sort of strange
things with the storytelling okay I'm
technique so our game has no text no
dialogue it's all to visually through
these like very strange playable spaces
so it's all sort of like environmental
storytelling so you're in the alien
world then all of a sudden you're in
this space where you've sort of been
transported in time sometimes back to
earth sometimes to these places that you
can't identify but you basically learn
about the backstory of the game by
playing through these spaces they're
paying attention to what's happening
around here yeah I think that's a big
thing in these games where like the
environment tells most of the story you
don't get a lot of linear story I think
that's how they you can engage better
with the story yeah the game yeah you
have to sort of use your imagination and
piece it together these things together
so you said your one half of the hill
how long have you guys been working on
this game
yes I'm yes so there's two of us making
the game my deaf partners Steve Copeland
he's the engineer and the game designer
okay and I'm doing the art animation and
sound design oh boy yeah so we've been
working on the game full-time for about
four and a half years and we feel like
we're getting pretty close we haven't
announced a launch date yet but we're
hoping to do that within the year and at
the most and what platforms are you
looking a long time so the current plan
is to launch on PC
steam sort of all the major store fronts
and then will be taking it to all the
major consoles thank you so much for
your time really appreciated the game
looks great thank you thank you so much
all right this is our Lowe's podcast
signing out from PAX East 2019 check out
a new